[Music]
this hour President Trump will pitch his
tax reform plan into middletown
pennsylvania and we will bring the
speech to you live when it happens but
first to our top story developments in
the Harvey Weinstein scandal have been
fast and furious over the past 24 hours
we've learned that the movie mogul has
boarded a flight to Europe for sex rehab
as more victims have now come forward
the latest being Cara Delevingne
who claims she was a victim of his
unwanted advances and there's more new
reports about how Weinstein was perhaps
protected first up
NBC News here's Ronan Farrow on how the
network refused to first report on this
story why did you end up recording this
story for The New Yorker and not for NBC
News look you would have to ask NBC and
NBC executives about the details of that
story I'm not going to comment on any
news organizations story that they you
know did or didn't run I will say that
over many years many news organizations
have circled this story and faced a
great deal of pressure in doing so and
then there's Hollywood did they know
about Weinstein's abuses and sit by and
do nothing this video from more than
four years ago may prove so oh please
I'm not afraid of anyone in show
business
I turned down intercourse with Harvey
Weinstein on no less than three
occasions out of five congratulations
you five ladies no longer have to
pretend to be attracted to Harvey
Weinstein
all right so Dana do you think this is
it perhaps just the tip of the iceberg
no I mean listen the the laughter
doesn't sound so funny you now I'm
looking back and suppose I guess knowing
what they knew at the time I do have to
say I'm really impressed with Ronan
Farrow and how composed she was I mean
that's not easy to do an interview at
least they did the interview on MSNBC
and the parent company the question
being did they actually stifle the story
that Ronan had worked on for quite a
while and they said no take it somewhere
else and then he takes it to the New
Yorker I thought that was pretty
remarkable that perhaps it is a lot more
widespread and Chris Hayes who is a host
at MSNBC said you have to wonder if
Hollywood is staring at something that
would be as big as the scandal that the
Catholic Church went through 15 years
ago yeah and you had a good discussion
about that today I mean the other thing
Dana just default really quickly is Seth
MacFarlane had said that he had heard
about it or knew about it was making the
jokes for the at least or some
suggestion that there was some knowledge
and discussion about it sort of maybe
behind the scenes etc and Hollywood so
where do they go from here it's
interesting because you know a lot of
places have gone through this and you
look back and you think well was it if
you might have heard about it but it
maybe you didn't have anything personal
to do with it so you think well that's
none of my business but a lot of these
actresses that have come forward and
some of their former boyfriends or
current boyfriends who had said that
they did try to confront him directly
they didn't take it public and partly
that's because they're in a business
together and they want to succeed but I
do wonder if at this point they're
realizing that they have a much bigger
problem on their hands because they were
they were laughing about it excusing it
but you actually might have legal action
that will take him pronto I think it's
very curious Kimberly I'm curious what
you think about this why did Harvey
Weinstein have to go overseas I mean is
there not an opportunity to go to one of
these places in America I'm not I've
never looked into it but I did yes
that's very hard it's thanks for that
revealing personal planning we have to
be clear when we're praising Ronan
Farrow for doing what for bringing up
NBC's role in this so we have to do that
with ourselves correct I mean where we
all shouting about FNC when that was
going on
so I can see why people hide they call
this an open secret which means it's not
a secret right that's that's what drives
me crazy and it is because there's a
certain generation of men perhaps that
see in places of power as things is
transactional you know the people have
an it word for this
Minoo p'n secret that it's called the
casting couch so it's not just about
Weinstein it's about everybody they know
that when a young girl is going in to do
they could think someone will always
make a joke about the casting couch well
this is kind of what Dana was talking
about in terms of the Chris Hayes suite
which was okay is this something that
we're gonna see obviously that's been
talked about the casting couch that was
sort of systemic in Hollywood will there
be other people who are reveal but it's
just you've aged in the same practices
it's not it it's old school it's it's
wherever there's high-powered executives
where there are directors there are
producers there are politicians you are
going to see somebody violating this a
lot of people get into certain
businesses precisely because of this
some guy wants to get in the movies
because he wants to get laid okay what I
mean I'm thinking honesty to Greg's
point in all industries men continue to
abuse their power and it's starting to
slow down as lights been exposed to this
RV looks like a serial sexual predator
and it was an open secret and it's so
cliche when you think about it that a
ugly fat old Hollywood producer dangles
the dream of success in front of a young
starlet on a casting couch the
stereotype is is just so sick but they
don't have to be so physically
attractive or not the point is it happen
but either way the the cliche is true if
you look at them now if you look at the
industry of Hollywood there's so limited
amount of roles that these women are
pursuing and there's only a few big
production houses in Hollywood so you
have a few rich powerful men like
Weinstein who control and are the
keepers for very very hotly contested
roles so you have women coming across
from from Europe from Asia from all over
the country to compete and try to land
their dream job and he preys on their
dreams and he exploits their dreams for
sexual gratification now it's it's not
the victims fault for not coming forward
but like you said it was so open that
everybody knew about it and instead of
doing something about it they put their
own self-preservation and their own
success and their own access above doing
the right thing so Hollywood so
self-congratulatory
and self-righteous you see them at the
award shows patting themselves on the
back they decide that they're the
arbiters of what's right what's
appropriate in this country and they're
quick to point the finger when any of
their enemies cross the moral lines that
they've designated but the fact that
this went on for so long and they did
nothing completely undercuts their
credibility when they championed the
causes that they claim to won a champion
okay just so you know one let's touch on
upon the most important aspect of this
which is the victims there's many
reasons why people don't come forward
they don't feel that they have economic
power or a voice that will be heard many
of them want to make sure that they can
try to get a chance in the industry and
it's you know very uncomfortable some
people said they didn't want to come
forward out of not to embarrass his
family or wife or children that type of
thing
or they feel just you know humiliated
himself shame at that I mean I dealt
with that a lot with them sexual assault
you know victims and people who were
rape sex abuse crimes where they don't
want to come forward because of the
stigma I think there's so much changing
in the country with regard to the
relationships between men and women but
in the workplace exactly what you say is
at plague Kimberly because I think lots
of women saw this as an opportunity to
get ahead so we know about the women
who've come forward and said Harvey
Weinstein behaved inappropriately what's
not said oftentimes was the woman who
may have had some relationship and it
might have advanced their career we even
I've read in the paper day one woman had
his initials tattooed on her because you
know he made her career but now all of a
sudden I think people feel like we know
what
Weinstein isn't Jessie said a clear
sexual predator and the question becomes
not just Hollywood but as we're seeing
in the papers today what about the
politicians who were taken Harvey
Weinstein's money from the Clintons to
the Obamas why were those people silent
and again you come back to the idea that
you know what he had power he had money
and men like sex and they want sex with
younger women and here he had the
opportunity to act in a way that said
it's my prerogative it comes with the
power you know on Wall Street this is a
problem you've read about people in
Washington congressmen having affairs
and saying to the mistress let's have an
abortion even though he says that he is
you know pro-life and then you hear
about things I mean like John F Kennedy
and all the women that were around that
or you hear about I mean it's to me what
lot of what's going on on the college
campuses where the colleges don't know
how to deal when a young woman says that
the guy behaved inappropriate this is
you have this is different in the sense
that it is normalized when you have a
phrase called a casting couch and
everybody assumes and jokes about it
that means it is something that has
become acceptable to a point where well
did he hit on you yeah oh it's
disgusting I thought I didn't tell
anybody because everybody already knows
that Harvey does that so I didn't want
to tell anybody it grossed me out but
you know everybody knows they joke about
it on awards shows so it became it the
hypocrisy that Jesse brings up is so
true this is an industry that lectures
us on morality on all kinds of morality
whether it's about sex sexuality or
gender or climate change but in this
case they're accepting something that is
immoral because it is part of doing
business but it's not just them now yeah
I think it's been them forever no I
agree I just and I just think this is
the way business was done among powerful
men at a different time in a different
generation and at the moment you see
more women in the workforce more women
who were educated and they have
sufficient political leverage great to
finally call people out now the question
to me is so why didn't NBC approve Ronan
Farrow story why
The New Yorker approve it you know or
why didn't as I understand it several
years ago there was the argument the New
York Times had some of this they say
they didn't hope you know with whole the
story but boy it sure looks terrible NBC
then you know I'm pushed back then just
to say their side of it they say well
this is a different story than what was
presented to us so that's an interesting
factual analysis to see what did he
proffer and put forward and who in fact
made the call to not you know take that
story and go with it to the point that
it was buried and kept like this you
know but there was also intimidation
that he did to people when they try to
cross him or that they weren't you know
he wasn't forth he felt that they were
trying to do something against him like
Ronan said he had that problem with him
personally but I just want to touch on
something to you because when you think
about that about Roman Polanski and now
you see he's going to sex rehab in in
Europe and as a prosecutor I'm just
telling you the first thing I'm thinking
of wow this guy just skipped town where
did he go in Europe is he gonna be able
to be brought back as I even contacted
the Los Angeles District Attorney's
Office where I used to work and in terms
of the sexual assault unit and you know
you're looking at yes misdemeanor
battery even as three years felony if
there's rape and the victims adult at a
time there's a six-year statute of
limitations or aggravated rape forcible
rape of more than two victims that's in
this could be 15 to life we don't know
all the facts here what transpired but
it certainly warrants a full and
thorough criminal investigation for
assault of sexual conduct and what has
been so far alleged in terms of the
media and so if you're the LA DA's
office or whether stuff took place in
New York they have to be checking in but
they have prevented him from leaving the
country well if they had an open case
and we're aware and we're able to go or
if they were convening a you know grand
jury or something of that nature you can
try to prevent you know somebody from
leaving and putting out a warrant but
they might not have been there at this
point but when you see an investigation
like this I mean I've had cases where a
case was in front of a grand jury and
indictment was just about to be turned
that you know returned in the dog
mauling case and my two defendants fled
and there was a high-speed chase and the
whole deal so you know you've got to be
like on top of this stuff but I think
because this just broke now they're
getting interview know on top of the
investigation
that's why this is very important and
compelling news story from so many
angles
my guess is sex rehab is probably gonna
be a chateau in France and you're not
gonna yeah and also I can I say I never
knew what the phrase casting couch meant
until this show I know I'm Way too high
in July
I learned that faster yeah that was in
sitcoms
oh my goodness